you're a [ __ ] erudite man all
these [ __ ] schools you talking about
he dropped out of 9th grade but he's
saying erudite and i'm like what
you got the thesaurus on that i mean
you're an educator man oh no i just kept
getting kicked out yeah but you kept
going [ __ ] i want to play football far
but i'm glad i went to one school in the
overwrap
that's my whole uh no i was i was at
bowie state you know man you tell me you
passed all those tests and [ __ ]
i did just good enough on the sats yeah
to to get to get a scholarship but um
again like the program i was in it
wouldn't allow my grades to it took too
long because they never seen like no
school like that so it was just weird
process when i'm in prison i write the
greatest you know poetic letters and
[ __ ] and i still have them
no i don't even know how to start a
letter now
yeah you lost all your letters mike did
you did you draw a lot in prison i'm i'm
a horrible drawer yeah me too when you
say writing are you talking about you
like as a poet or you to your family
yeah the letter to my family how long
was you win again three and a half
did you work out or you was just
chilling yeah i got in shape i was i
went there like what
278 and left around 214. that's why he
was ready to eat [ __ ] family and kids
yeah that's why because you turned it
back [ __ ] yeah
did you get in any did [ __ ] ain't
going to smoke when he was locked up or
you got into some [ __ ] [ __ ] want to try
your name everybody just loves me it's
cool everybody just gave me what i need
they didn't want me to go there they
brought me food from the child line so
you don't got to go up there that's what
happens
the footage is out all right ready to
treat people already they already had
the tape on him so when he got that he
there's like oh no you good mike nah
listen all good i don't care how good
you fight them [ __ ] got crews and them
[ __ ] they're killing them [ __ ] up
there for murder they don't care about
killing nobody yeah
they don't care they're never coming
home they don't give a [ __ ] yeah that
people they shouldn't have put me in
prison for those guys man
you think it changed you
you think it changed you like as a
fighter you think that time changed you
at all
i was never the same fight i just think
that's just was the kind of environment
that i could thrive in this this is
where i've been on my life all my life
this has been most of my surroundings
then i started boxing and now i'm back
in there but once i i felt very normal
there
no more in there i feel very normal
there yeah i knew what to do here
in prison yeah who who's the first
fighter you got out i remember i think
it was
the london [ __ ] oh the white guy peter
mcnailly i'm the crazy guy from both
them bruno what's his name bruno frank
bruno frank bruno i remember that
commercial on fox he was like frank
bruno something something something and
it was like showing i'm not gonna go
frank bruno some some some so i'm
knocking that guy i don't know why these
moments stick with me but i was like yo
because he was mad like like but you
beat the [ __ ] he's a big guy beat the
[ __ ] out of him yeah did the people have
some crazy [ __ ] in prison did people
make like crazy [ __ ] like to like you
know defend themselves like you know
what i mean um yeah everybody had this
stuff but um
listen man um
somebody went like listen
like if he'll have a problem with you
you're never gonna see her again
she's sending somebody ain't gonna never
see her again and now you got somebody
after your head you're never gonna see
them again yeah
and now somebody's gonna come stab you
or chop your head off
this is not depicted on orange is the
new black
black the black everything goes here
not
you've had a lot of interesting
interviews
yeah yeah you'll get [ __ ] up i imagine
it's kind of like a hi you know it could
be
it may survive with a fittest
you know you have to be careful what you
say
be very careful what you say did you
still have the same um like confidence
when you came out like as far as like
being the greatest boxer in the world
yeah yeah i thought about it every day i
used to run in place in my room wow like
an hour and a half two weeks running
place running place right in place with
my headphones my radio did you ever in
your mind be like all right
i could beat all these [ __ ] except for
such and such and such as i might have a
problem with did you ever like in your
mind be like i'm like this might be this
guy might give me some problems well no
i didn't look at it from that
perspective right
i don't know if you can allow me to say
i just look at the mess
they're a food that's how you're
supposed to look at them your food yeah
how could they dare match me
yeah yeah you know you have to have that
kind of
perceptive perception of yourself right
it almost has to be thought status right
i agree in any field any field but more
so than when it's with when it's like
physical like no in combat physical
listen if you lose a rap battle it feels
just as bad that somebody knock you out
no it's probably a little
they can't get away from their
psychological pain
physical pain ain't [ __ ]
[Music]